what's the deal with airplane peanuts
peanuts
we're standing out here live in front of
the comedy Mothership after attending
the Joe Rogan and Friends showcase
earlier this week in this video I'm
going to be breaking down everything
that happened at the show putting
special guests saving arrangements and
debunking a few myths about this club
the line looked very long when we
arrived so they handled it kind of like
a Chick-fil-A splitting it into two
lines having people scan your tickets
check your IDs right here then put a
wristband on and you're free to enter
the club before entering the lobby
you're handed a Magnetic Locking back to
place your phone in and then you're good
to go I'm not sure if the report that
the comedy Mothership scans your face
before entering their building was
completely made up in the first place or
if they stop doing it entirely or maybe
they scanned all of our faces without
any of us knowing I don't know but I saw
nobody get a picture taken of their face
the entire time as soon as you walk in
the lobby you're greeted by a staff
member who points you towards the
showrooms my first thought walking into
the mothership was one this is [__]
awesome and two I can't believe how
small it is our show took place in the
fat man and the seating was extremely
intimate even in the bigger room there
was really not a bad seat in the house
the fat man has tables on the floor and
then extra chairs and Boots elevated on
one side so everyone's packed in there
right next to each other really the
perfect room to tell jokes in set up to
Foster new Talent too it's not just set
up to take care of existing Talent it's
set up so you create a nice comedy
environment where people can go and see
guys like Shane Gillis you guys like you
guys go up see guys like Greg
Fitzsimmons or you know Schultz was here
last week it was [__] amazing they
get to see these people coming together
you see Dave Chappelle show up you know
they're getting to see like the cream of
the crop come in that's why she's
comparison the door for that reason to
see better Comics exactly because it's
it's a massive part of the education we
wanted to make sure that that was like a
big part of what we were doing Joe Rogan
was on stage for about an hour and the
whole time it never stopped feeling kind
of bizarre that we were all sitting 10
feet away from one of the most famous
people on earth I don't know if this
really makes sense or if other people
who have been to the Mothership agree
with this but I'm so used to watching
Joe Rogan on video format and video form
that it almost felt fake seeing him
perform that close up in person not in
an arena and I wasn't wearing an Oculus
I was there on a Wednesday and the
lineup in order went Assange mod Brian
Simpson Jim Brewer Tony Hinchcliffe and
Joe Rogan to close it out the best part
about attending the Joe Rogan and
friends show is that you have no idea
who the friends are going to be heading
into the show so each comic that gets
called up is a complete surprise the
anticipation before each intro is
palpable in the room everyone is on the
edge of their seats to see if their
favorite comedian is about to walk on
stage like the very next night after I
was at the mothership Joey Diaz
surprised the audience completely
unannounced
I really wanted to go down there I
really really wanted to go see what Joe
had done it wasn't about the podcast it
wasn't about smoking weed and you know
he opened the club and he worked so hard
and I just wanted to go down there and
see what he did and I'll tell you what
I'm happy I [__] did man as far as
the actual show goes I honestly thought
it was the perfect order to start to
finish it was really cool to see Jim
Brewer that was the first time I've seen
a real physical comedian he hit the deck
like four times in 15 minutes Joe Rogan
on stage for an hour was by far the
coolest part but the funniest set had to
either be Brian Simpson or Tony
Hinchcliffe that was my second time
seeing Tony live and if you only know
him from host and kill Tony please go
see him as soon as he's in town next
because it was amazing and he was on
fire start to finish abortion
is now illegal in the state of Alabama a
state in which abortion should be
mandatory
really the only qualms I can think of
with attending a show at the mothership
is one they need to get speakers in the
bathroom playing the audio from the show
and two if you ask for water they'll
bring you an eight dollar liquid death
which is kind of annoying but it's also
helping pay comedians the best club
wages on Earth so whatever everybody
came off stage with a smile whether they
were like a door guy or door girl doing
five minutes or someone like Ron White I
would highly encourage comedians to come
here but also just to do your weekend
like book weekends do it at comedy
Mothership let them know if you're a
comic that you want to work there
because it's hot and it's fun it's
really fun it reminds me of like the
great clubs in the country where you're
like when you go to Comedy Works in
Denver Acme in Minneapolis where you're
like man that was fun as [__] is fire
it's the same kind of vibe there like
audiences that are stoked to be there
and know how to behave and they take
their phones all the [__] that you
wish happened happens there guest spots
from last week your mom's house had on
Jay Larson two bears one cave was Burton
Tom kill Tony this week was with Ari
shaffir and Big Jay oakerson Alonzo bone
was on the Harlan Highway Mark Norman
was a guest on Matt and Shane's secret
podcast whiskey ginger head on the
Broken Lizard boys we might be drunk
head on Miss Pat and Dan Soder was a
guest on the Young's Papa sour as well
as Ru garbage here's Dwayne Reed two
blocks away from that you're just in
there hanging out I was buying something
hey we need anything I really didn't
have the thought when I was buying
something the other day where I was like
probably gonna get to know everyone that
works here
I want to be a regular Dwayne Reed
yeah you doing Sam those birthday cards
are looking stock hey got the Easter
stuff in already yeah oh yeah 50 off huh
it's like get that bunny the [__] out of
here anyways who's working the register
today you know you made it when the
deodorant's not locked up oh they give
you the key God damn we trust you here's
the little red team yeah imagine having
your own key I would love that dude keys
to the place
you're a good kid I'm gonna go get these
gillettes I'll go get these raisins dude
everything stay and watch the register I
gotta run I gotta run and take a piss
real quick
you have a phone number with us you're
selling the card do you want to sign up
today I would sign up you know you're
gonna get like 15 off this past weekend
with the Yvonne talked with John Mulaney
Colin Quinn was on the Tim Dylan show
Colin Quinn was also on Chrissy chaos
The Joe Rogan Experience had the classic
Uncle Joey episode Ronnie Chang was on
tigerbelly Chase O'Donnell was on the
Honeydew Hassan Minaj was on the blocks
podcast take your shoes off with Rick
Glassman also talked with Jay Larson and
Joe list and big J were both on you know
what dude as far as new stand-up
specials that are either out right now
or coming out soon John Mulaney baby Jay
came out on Netflix yesterday that had a
lot of Comedy fans really excited after
hearing him talk about it on this past
weekend but the special is called Baby J
which is something I refer to myself as
special because the people like when 40
year old men call themselves baby Jay
people find that really cute and like
that a lot yeah yeah do you think is it
like about being like a late bloomer
what is it what what is it kind of in
relation to I don't know I just refer to
myself as it at one point in the special
and it makes me laugh a lot oh nice
actually Gavin live in Chicago is also
out right now on YouTube as well as Jay
Larson sounds like Bruce I'm gonna go on
a limb here too and say you have like a
1950s like table and chairs in your
kitchen is that true
damn
you're literally like two years away
from having a bird in the house that's
that's where you're going that's the
route
is this your guy
nice hey dude
how's it going man
what are you into what'd you pick up
during the pandemic anything
MMA you sound like a perfect couple
other specials coming out soon jimmyo
Yang's new special is coming out Tuesday
May 2nd that'll be hosted on Amazon
Prime also another thing to add about
the experience at the comedy Mothership
it felt very unique sitting in that
crowd versus other Comedy Club crowds
that I've been in just because you know
everyone in there is equally as excited
to be in Joe Rogan's club and the
tickets sell out so fast are so hard to
get you got to make plans some people
are visiting from other states or
countries even that you know everyone in
there is very grateful to be at the show
and eager to laugh it was also really
cool meeting some joke World subscribers
after the show and talking about our
favorite jokes and comedians in general
if you're visiting Austin Texas anytime
soon I would definitely recommend
visiting the comedy Mothership it more
than delivers but in the meantime feel
free to subscribe to joke world for the
next best thing thanks for watching also
next time you go to the comedy
Mothership let me know if this joke
World sticker is still there I put it up
here I had to jump we should have filmed
that actually that would have been fun
I'll do another one right now actually
I'm not gonna put another one on the
same phone
foreign
[Music]